[Music]
you weren't that impressed with his
first movie he wasn't your favorite
Avenger now get ready for the sequel
that made everyone say polish who knew
Captain America kicked so much ass
Captain America the Winter Soldier the
captain is back and he didn't skip leg
day thrill as he ditches his lame
Avenger suit for a cool new one and
shows up the full range of his vaguely
defined superpowers like super
gymnastics super throwing super catching
and super jumping out of stuff
[Music]
see where to parachute when he's not
kicking ass or taking names follow cab
as he spends his free time freaking out
kids at museums
hanging with his gills and catching up
on the last 60 years of pop culture I'll
put it on the list
man star wars must have blown his mind
when Hydra returns cap needs to take him
out by forming a team he can trust
including Black Widow a sneaky double
agent who he really shouldn't trust and
Falcon a random guy he met on the street
Sam Roth Steve Rogers watch his cab and
two non superheroes end up actually
taking a lot of ass together in a really
entertaining well directed movie what we
have to be honest it's good but since
honest trailers is a comedy series get
ready for dead pig age prepare for the
shocking revelation that Hydra has been
secretly growing inside of shield all
along despite the fact that the previous
Marvel movies really didn't do anything
to set that up and get ready to try to
ignore questions like when did they fury
stop wearing the bulletproof vests that
save his life in the Avengers
why didn't oni stork find out about
hydra when he decrypted all of shields
files in few hours all now every dirty
secret Shield is ever trying to hide how
did an agency that employs thousands of
people hide the fact that half of its
agents were members of a secret Nazi
death cult for over 60 years
if shield had their hands on the
tesseract for so long why didn't hide
her just use that to take over the world
that was the red skulls plan in the
first place right and he was the og
Hydra and if Nick Fury was such a threat
why didn't hide her try to kill him
before he saved Tony Stark's life
thought out their greatest enemy and
assembled a team of superheroes
that would almost certainly stop any
evil plans they had for the future see
we told you it'd be nitpicking so sit
back and enjoy the best standalone
Marvel movie since Iron Man full of
awesome action awesome cameos and one
awesome twist they run into the ground
where Bucky turns out to still be alive
and dr. Zola turns out to still be alive
and Nick Fury turns out to still be
alive and crossbone turns out him okay
no one ever really dies in this movie
still great though starring American
Austin Powers mad-eye moody on frozen
caveman soldier lucy falcon punch
robert red Toyota and hail hard drive
Captain America he's cool now so cap
it's the safety of the free world on two
people not wanting to buy gum not a
great plan be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers
nanu-nanu Oh captain my captain ten
thousand years will give you such a
crick in the neck
morning Vietnam carpe diem seize the day
boys make your lives extraordinary